voir a quoi ressemble cette
lutte.
- Ah c'est vraiment un petit
paradis ici, vraiment, vraiment.
♪ ♪ ♪
Un petit paradis nommé Terrebonne.
Diane et Lucien ont choisi de s'y installer
à temps plein il y a 10 ans.
- Avant, on était toujours en
Floride, mais on n'y va plus,
on est bien mieux ici.
- Et ils sont de plus en plus nombreux
à s'établir à Terrebonne pour sa localisation près de Montréal
et Laval, à proximité de 2 autoroutes notamment.
La ville grandit, les projets domiciliaires poussent
un peu partout.
Mais Terrebonne a aussi connu
son lot de perturbations.
L'UPAC a frappé en 2016. Cinq personnes, dont l'ex-maire,
ont été arrêtés. Puis, aux dernières élections,
les citoyens ont choisi
Marc-André Plante.
MARC-ANDRÉ PLANTE, candidat
- On avait besoin de faire
le ménage, de moderniser
l'administration municipale puis
aujourd'hui, on est en meilleure poste.
Terrebonne se transforme, mais se transforme
d'une belle façon.
- Il sollicite un deuxième
mandat. Sa promesse : protéger le porte-feuille de ses citoyens.
- Son principal adversaire mise
plutôt sur le changement.
MATHIEU TRAVERSY, candidat
- Ça prend une nouvelle
approche. Donc au cours,
malheureusement, du dernier
mandat, il y a eu de division, beaucoup
de confrontation.
- (ensemble) : Terrebonne, Terrebonne!
- Le conflit avec les employés municipaux
s'est invité dans la
campagne. Ces derniers dénoncent
un climat de travail toxique.
JOËL GOULET, Intersyndical Terrebonne
Congés de maladie à répétition,
départs précipités à la retraite,
de nombreuses plaintes
en harcèlement. Il y a aussi une démotivation
qui est généralisée à la ville
de Terrebonne.
La cour est pleine.
- Tous les grands syndicats de la ville, pompiers,
policiers, cols blancs, cols bleus,
ont formé une alliance en 2019.
Certaines conventions
collectives sont échues depuis 3 ans.
- Oui, on a de bonnes
conditions. Ce qu'on dénonce,
encore une fois, c'est vraiment
le climat de travail qui est toxique à la ville de
Terrebonne, la diminution
des services aux employés.
Et nous, on pense qu'on a besoin
d'un vent nouveau pour aller
se rasseoir aux tables de négociations.
- Mais il faut s'assurer que
la progression du coût des
conventions collectives, suive
la progression des revenus de la Ville.
Je ne peux malheureusement pas,
pour les familles et les
retraités, dire qu'on va piger
à nouveau dans leur portefeuille
pour financer ces conventions collectives.
Il faut trouver un équilibre.
- L'environnement aussi est au
coeur de la campagne électorale.
On veut que Terrebonne puisse faire sa part
au niveau de la lutte aux changements
climatiques. On a vu qu'à
l'échelle locale, on était capable d'avoir des changements
qui ont finalement une influence
sur le global, et donc, on veut
apporter notre contribution
aussi dans cette lutte
environnementale. Il est aussi beaucoup question
d'améliorer la mobilité durable puisque la congestion
est importante à l'heure de pointe.
- Les gouvernements péquistes et libéraux
nous ont beaucoup délaissé sur la couronne nord
au cours des décennies. On a eu beaucoup
de promesses, mais aujourd'hui, il est temps d'investir.
- Il y a beaucoup de gens qui
s'en viennent en banlieue,
fait que la circulation
devient de plus en plus dense.
- On paye des grosses taxes,
hein. Ça fait que, c'est ça, il y a l'hiver, le déneigement.
L'été, ce n'est pas propre,
les rues, ce n'est pas propre.
- Pour moi, c'est l'environnement. C'est l'une des
causes principales que je vais
voter. C'est déjà fait
d'ailleurs.
- Plus de 14 % des citoyens ont déjà voté
par anticipation à Terrebonne. C'est pratiquement
deux fois plus qu'en 2017.
Ici Kim Vermette, Radio-Canada, à Terrebonne.